welcome to this meeting of the council
I'm councilor Catherine Grandin chairman
of baber District Council and I will be
chairing the meeting today
Maya first of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May recalled film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
before I move on to the agenda I would
like to welcome if D Ali our new interim
director for Law and governance and
monitoring officer to the council
welcome mifty
can I move to the agenda now please
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies from counselors Ayers Dawson
hardacre Lindsay Nunn Mabry malvasi
McCraw Parker and Melanie Barrett thank
you
thank you
item two Declarations of Interest by
councilors
all councilors have been granted
dispensation from the monitoring officer
to discuss the independent remuneration
report item 18.
and members who are on Boards of the
council's companies have also been
granted dispensation from the monitoring
officer with regard to item 11 on the
agenda
are there any other Declarations of
Interest
thank you
item three
paper BC 2224
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 6th October 2022 for accuracy
only
I refer you to the minutes in the tabled
papers
are there any issues with accuracy
could I have a proposer please
thank you Adrian Osborne
may I have a second to please
thank you
um
councilor plum
all those in favor will have a show of
hands please
thank you that's carried
item four
BC 2225
announcements from the chairman and
leader
first I refer you to paper BC 2225 for
noting
and then I'd just like to mention that
um as you as some of you might know
um I'm supporting a breast cancer
charity and I've got an event happening
on the 28th of January and I'd love it
if as many of you as possible can come
there will be more details forward in in
the near future hopefully but it'll be
lovely if you can put it in your Diaries
thank you
I'd now like to invite councilor Ward to
make his announcements councilor Ward
thank you chairman
I don't have much to say this evening as
I did Cover a lot in my announcements at
the meeting we had earlier this month
but I do just want to mention a few
things but before I do I have to say
it's incredibly disappointing that the
conservative group has decided to
boycott in a fit of peak this evening
it's not good for democracy and it does
their residence a great disservice
to use a phrase that uh councilor Simon
Barrett uses very often it's not a good
look
moving on
along with councilors Busby and Dawson I
recently went on a site visit and photo
shoot to our former officers in Hadley
to view the works and talk to the
Developers good progress has been made
and expect that the first Apartments
will be on sale next summer
I also visited the new West Suffolk
operational Hub last week with councilor
zathi Busby and malhiti this is an
excellent facility that combines
facilities for their vehicles storage
workshops a waste transfer station and a
household waste recycling center and it
does give us appointed to what we could
do as we look to providing a new Depot
for our districts
last week the second baber mid-suffolk
Innovation award ceremony was held and
unlike the first which was an online
event held during lockdown two years ago
this time it was a Gala evening at
Western Park
unfortunately I was unable to be there
as it clashed with a wedding in
Warwickshire but from all the reports
I've received it was a great success
there were very worthy winners and a
strong field of candidates that
represented breadth of businesses across
our districts and which show that
Innovation is happening in many sectors
there were 22 finalists in eight
categories and also a business business
innovator of the Year award
I really want to say a big thank you to
the economic development and
Communications teams for putting in a
huge amount of effort to make the
evening so successful and so much fun
for everyone
and finally I just want to make a plea
for the town and Parish Council briefing
notes
each month we produce this Roundup of
all that has happened in Bieber for you
to pass on to your communities at town
and Parish Council meetings
these are designed to be entirely
factual and non-political and are there
to make your reporting job easier
I do urge you all to use them either
verbatim or to weave them into your own
narrative should you wish
they are informative and do contain the
sorts of things that the public would
find interesting
if anyone has any ideas for improving
them please let us know
thank you Jim
item five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you item six questions by the
public in accordance with Council
procedure rules
thank you chair non-received thank you
item seven questions by councilors in
accordance with Council of procedure
rules
thank you again none received thank you
item eight paper BC
2226 overview excretionary committee
report
I would like to invite councilor Hinton
to introduce his report
councilor Hinton
thank you
I'm not going to cover in detail the
work of overview and scrutiny the
information is a matter of record but I
would like to highlight the main items
that we've covered
in June 2022 the cifco business trading
and performance report was covered
after one lost motion it was unanimously
recorded that full Council will always
be kept in the loop on sifco's
performance and not just when things go
wrong
it's important that all councilors have
ownership of this important work
joint ons were content with the report
from cifco and that is reported to you
join ons approved the statements in your
papers concerning the activities of
Cisco and the holding companies
recent uncertainty in financial markets
and the economic outlook for the country
may make more frequent scrutiny a
possibility
but that's just a flag attached to the
mast at the moment not run up at all
in September 2022 the committee looked
at the parking strategy for the council
this is the first time that the council
has had a parking strategy and there was
some concern over the urban-centric
proposals but it was noted that the
parking strategy implementation plan was
a more constructive phase for their
ideas
the committee did agree on a list of
comments for cabinet and these were
reported and formed part of your papers
the same meeting shared Revenue
partnership proposals for the council
tax reduction scheme were scrutinized
and option 3 was recommended which
proposes 100 discount in certain
circumstances
this was regarded as a win-win option as
it was best for recipients staff and
Council finances
an information bulletin was received
from shared Legal Services which
highlighted the splitting workloads and
the varying complexity of the cases
referred
Salient points are in your paper and the
bulletin was noted
finally the task and finish group on
Rural transport gave its final report
for baber the recommendations are in the
papers perhaps of most significance is
the need for improved communication
between the regulatory bodies in the
area Suffolk County Council baber
District Council and Parish councils to
reduce the impact of living in the
countryside in line with our green
initiatives
our population has a higher percentage
of over 65s in rural locations where
costs are approximately 20 percent
higher than in urban equivalents
this needs to be reflected in all our
governing governmental bodies decision
making
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank all the committee members from
both councils and substitutes for their
constructive inputs into the workings of
the committee
thank you councilor Hinton are there any
questions for councilor Hinton
thank you if there are no questions
we'll move on to the next item
item nine to receive reports from
cabinet members
I would like to invite councilor Busby
to introduce his report
cmu1 Cabinet member for assets and
Investments thank you thank you chair
um
well it's such a fantastically concise
and comprehensive report I'm sure you've
all read it twice so I don't propose to
go through it or add anything to it if
there's any questions from the
opposition
I wouldn't be with there's nobody here
if anybody else has got a question would
you like to email me the question and
I'll make sure it's circulated to every
council member thanks
thank you councilor Busby
now item 10 recommendations from cabinet
committees
10A Jac
2133 annual treasury management report
2021-22
I would like to invite councilor Horan
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendation on the agenda councilor
Huron
thank you madam chairman
shame there's so few of us I feel as if
I've got nobody to project here um
and I take the point said earlier shame
on our democracy but here is the
treasury management outdone report 21
22. it seems a while since we met so
it's a bit historic four months we met
in July to sign this off
this is the joint treasury manager
report covering the position for the out
term for the financial year 21-22
it provides details of the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the reports explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities including the regulatory
framework economic conditions interest
rates and liquidity risk
major issues over this period whether
economic recovery from the coronavirus
pandemic the war in Ukraine higher
inflation and higher interest rates
inflation which was 0.7 in March
therefore began to steadily increase
helped by the wholesale surges and gas
and electricity prices and in February
inflation was at 6.2 that's up for over
five percent and now is approaching
nearly 10 percent so it gives the signs
for um a difficult working year I would
feel
bank rate was tenth of one percent at
the beginning of the reporting period
however to combat Rising reflect
inflation the bank of England increased
it to naught 0.75 three quarters of one
percent by March and it's now
approaching three so once again an
indicator of um increasingly difficult
times
the government's Furler scheme hadn't
insulated the labor market from the
worst effects of the pandemic having
peaked at 5.2 in December 20
unemployment continued to fall in the
labor market data for the three months
to January 22 slowed the unemployment
rate to 3.9
specifically for baber the council
continue to hold additional cash from
government grants receive relating to
covert 19.
this has much increased treasury
investment and activity during the year
regarding banking activities the council
operated within the daily bank account
limits except for one occasion when it
exceeded its daily limit as amended as
mentioned in appendix C
paragraph four one
the council during this year has
decreased its debt by 6.7 million pounds
and I could say that all investment
activities undertaken were approved with
the approved counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of this report
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure the
investment activity undertaken for the
year was done so in priority order of
security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
I will be pleased to propose the noting
of this paper which I think is 3.3 on
your papers and I would like to thank my
committee because unlike this meeting
we've had a pretty good um attendance
from both councils and from both sides
of the chamber and we've worked hard and
also the um the officers I think I
should thank them because
um without them we would not um so by
we're the amateurs of the councilors but
we rely on them but we work hard
together and it's been a successful year
I would feel
I've got a bit of a Husky I've always
could have had a toothache or tooth
extracted recently and I've still got
the stitches in but um I'll do my best
to answer anything but I have a friend
sitting over in the um
in in the offices Gallery here I'm sure
I can phone if I need help thank you
everybody
award thank you
we'll now move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question are there any questions
councilor Hinton
thank you madam chairman uh just a quick
one I'm sure it's a simple answer
because it doesn't cover a vast amount
of funding but I noticed that funding
circles still figuring our treasury
investment position and I understood
that we were going to divest ourselves
of all interests in funding Circle loans
so I was interested to know
when we hoped to get that down to zero
and remove funding circle from our
Investment Portfolio
thank you councilor Hinton councilor
Huron
I think if counselor Hinton wants um
an update as of now I'll call on Melissa
to do that it's obviously changed since
this paper was written
thank you Jack
um I don't have the details of where
we're at with funding Circle but we are
about to embark on our half-year
treasury management report and that will
be coming to join audit standards the
end of November so I will have an update
unless you'd like to read an answer
before then
foreign
are there any further questions
right if there are no further questions
we'll move on to debate councils will
only be allowed to speak once for three
minutes and this will be timed
would anyone like to open the debate
there's no one wishing to open the
debate
um councilor Harem is there anything you
would like to add
no thank you chairman I think it's all
in the paper I have actually read this
twice so um I do know it's accurate
um so nothing to add except happy to
propose it and we'll move on into well
probably tougher times but we are up for
it
thank you councilor Huron in that case
um I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for counselors to cost their
vote
councilor Adrian Osborne are you having
technical problems can I take your vote
manually please thank you
chair that is 16-4 unanimous
juice paper BC 22 27 and to move the
recommendations in the report councilor
Busby
thank you
I was hoping there was going to be some
debate on the treasury paper I had to
swallow my Murray mint
anyway I'm delighted to introduce this
report to full Council today albeit
somewhat later than originally planned
and almost four months after the Cisco
business plan was considered by the ons
Committee in June
this plan looks at performance during
21-22 Financial year and sets kpis in
the direction of travel for 22-23
financial year
during 2122 sifco continued to deliver
much needed income to our councils and
also made a significant profit with the
value of the portfolio growing by some
12 percent
whilst the current economic climate is
uncertain sifco has proved to be well
managed and resilient in the face of
challenging conditions such as the
pandemic and will continue to be so as
it faces the current challenges of
inflation higher interest rates and the
cost of living crisis
so if Co invested in the portfolio
during the last Financial year to
improve the quality and sustainability
credentials of our buildings including
the installation installation of solar
panels and
continuing to improve the sustainability
of the portfolio
baber benefited from about two million
pounds of net income last year a total
of 4.9 since IFCO started trading in
2017. all of which can be put into our
services helping our communities and is
particularly important at the current
time and therefore I'd like to propose
the recommendations
four three one the council notes IFCO
Capital limited trading activity and
performance for the year to the 31st of
March 2022
Council approves cifco capital limited
to 22 23 business plan for adoption by
cifco Capital limited and that future
cifco business plans are scrutinized by
The council's Joint ons committee and
only reported to council if the
committee is not satisfied with the
company's business plan and performance
or if a decision is required that is
reserved to four councils
can I have a second please
thank you Youngwood Council Ward
and um if you have any questions of
course we have
team
it's like um university challenge isn't
it
a team of experts on hand to ask them
thanks
so we'll now move to questions uh
councilors may ask as many questions
they wish however they must be relevant
to their subject under discussion and
must be a question
would someone like to open the questions
counselor Hamilton thank you
thank you madam chairman
um just a little bit concerned about the
recommendation 3.3
and it does actually say only reported
to council if the committee is not
satisfied with the company's business
plan and performance
or a decision is required that is
reserved to full councils
the overview and scrutiny committee
specifically recorded a motion which
said that they would always be reported
to council so that full council could
stay in
and information
informed as to what was going on at
Cisco and be involved the whole time
even if only on an information basis
rather than a decision-making basis so
I'm a little bit concerned about 3.3 and
I don't think that 3.3
should be included because it's contrary
to what overview and scrutiny pastors
emotion
that does seem to be a clash of
recommendations it goes and as I read it
I thought I thought that's the case I
think we should take the recommendations
straight from from the ons
uh report on that then
uh
yes that the overview and scrutiny
committee recommend of all Council of
future cifco business plans continue to
be scrutinized by the council's Stuart o
s committee and then reported to council
I mean I think that's right we
for information purposes only it's an
important part of our business now and
you should know what's going on so I
think we need to propose that as an
amendment then you're proposing it thank
you can I have secondary councilor
Hinton thank you
um chair through you you don't need to
it's your report so actually you can
make that Amendment
um if because you're going to accept it
anyway we're going to ask you if you
accept it and you say yes so you're
going to put that forward as a an
amendment amendment to your own report
so that's fine
[Laughter]
are there any other questions
thank you councilor Jameson
thank you madam chair since this I mean
Paul my business plan was put together
the I imagine the economic situation is
deteriorating drastically and gets worse
almost weekly and I find the mitigations
if any are in place to offset the
um CPI expected CPR for next year and
and other issues
well there are a whole host of things
that we're going to be trying to do
obviously
um
in terms of repairs
work on sustainability obviously we
might have to trim back on some of that
I think the biggest one is the may be
referred to as the interest rates
that the money's borrowed it's about
affects if though but it will affect the
council
um
Melissa has been doing a lot of work on
that
and it has changed considerably over the
last month we had a report from Ireland
close I think it was in September
and everything everything was Rosy we're
looking at one and a half percent
interest rates now we're looking at four
and a half percent so it'll make a
difference
um but there are there is money out
there to be borrowed and we will be
doing our best to borrowage at the
cheapest rate
we can so it continues to be
below what we're prepared to pay for
that
so beautiful so is there any forecasts
on how that might you know what we might
be looking at next year in terms of
our system will do based on
expectations
it shouldn't affect the rents uh the
rents have kept up very well that 98
percent
paid in the last quarter
and that's the most important thing
that's the income
as for the difference between what we
borrow at and what we lend at
I don't know what the figure will be
hopefully it'll be we can lend it
um at a greater rate than we're
borrowing it
but not at a too high rate than it's
kind of cripples
I mean
who knows what interest rates are going
to be we know that pwlb at the moment is
around four and a half five percent
doesn't go any higher than that I think
we'll be okay we can certainly borrow
short term and less than that and that's
what we will do
we continue to use short-term funds
whenever we can
any other questions
thank you
um
as the questions have finished we'll now
move to debate
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
would anyone like to open the debate
councilor Hinton
thank you chairman uh really just the
point of reassurance for
um
colleague here and that is that as I
mentioned in my report
scrutiny will be looking very carefully
at the activities of zifco to make sure
that we're responding in good time to
any changes in the economic situation
that comes along and I'm sure that he
would be pleased to come along and sub
it if necessary or come along to the
committee meetings and see what's
happening
thank you councilor Hinton Council award
thank you madam chairman well this this
really is good news isn't it I think
now we're finding the position where we
can Silence the Critics I can't imagine
anyone now could have anything that they
could say against cifco
as we can see from from the report here
the portfolio is recovering well
the rent collections exceed the kpi the
full debt repayment has been made to the
councils and this is um showing it it is
recovered very strongly and quickly from
the pandemic
and I I know what's uh councilor Jameson
said about the current financial crisis
but I think we can be safe uh and
reassured that it will we will sifco
will recover from the problems we're
going through now
um the fundamentals don't change as it
says in section 4.4
due to the work of the board and the
professional team
the quality of the assets and the
diverse portfolio none of that has
changed it seems through the pandemic
and it will see us through the current
financial crisis
just want to pick out some of the
numbers
in the report it shows that the
portfolio value has increased by 12.15
percent that's over 10 million pounds in
that year
we've now heard from Council Busby that
the and in the report that the the
income now to the baby District Council
in the in the past year in 2021-22 was
just over 2 million the cumulative
income is now in excess of 5 million
and
I'm looking at the value of the
portfolio the purchase price 91 million
and is now valued at 94 million so all
of the numbers are looking exceptionally
good
so really quite honestly
sifco's doing exactly what it was
intended to do it's a great success
and if he were here I would actually
congratulate councilor Barrett he was
one of the the principal drivers of
sifco and getting it through Council six
years ago when the paper came to council
it was proposed by my predecessor as
leader and councilor Barrett as Deputy
leader seconded it and he
um he put in a lot of effort to ensure
that sifco was set up and in order to
deliver what it is delivering to these
councils so
congratulations and thank you to
councilor Barrett
you know after
that no I mean yeah
um the MTC thank you thank you madam
chairman
can I just ask uh perhaps Chris if you
want uh
like to uh put your five Penny just how
you think that the next 12 months is
like to go I think it's probably covered
in the report which I mean it's a very
in-depth report but as we said the
situation has changed since we wrote
that report somewhat so perhaps you
could just
um look forward for us
yeah thank you David
um yes I mean it is it's very difficult
to predict what is going to happen but
um I think as Council Ward said the the
important thing is that the fundamentals
in the portfolio it's a it's a diverse
portfolio set across different sectors
uh with different sizes different a good
range of tenants
um we've obviously had a very
challenging couple of years with the the
portfolio and I'm absolutely delighted
and that's really the hard work of all
the team that the you know the rents
have held out held out we've had some
challenges but we've got through that
the important thing about this portfolio
obviously as far as our shareholders is
concerned
um is that this is It's fundamentally as
an income portfolio and that's how we
see it and that one of the the key roles
of the board really is looking to see at
that the strength of the income you know
we're looking ahead there are there are
some times in 26 perhaps when there are
some leases coming to an end and and
times like that so we're looking very
hard now at how we negotiate with
talents to make sure that
um that to take the risk out of some of
those those circumstances and I I think
I'm speaking for the board I think that
the feeling is that over the next year
or two
um the portfolio does look strong there
will be challenges there may be
challenges in terms of valuation but the
important thing as far as this support
value is concerned is that it's an
income fund
um and it is continuing to produce that
income obviously it was mentioned
earlier as well about sustainability and
that is a key focus of the board to to
improve the sustainability of the
portfolio but
our shareholders need to bear in mind
that all that most of the property law
the property is really Less on for
repairing ensuring leases and so
therefore there are only limited
occasions when we can really we can
invest or we can work to improve the
sustainability of the portfolio but that
is certainly something which is very
high up at the agenda of the board as
well
yeah thank you to Sir Christopher
Howarth
um
Council McLaren thank you
thank you madam chairman
um I think I want to probably with all
my colleagues congratulate you so if
you're in your team and the professional
team it was a joy to read the paper
in a week or a month or three months
that we've had some bad news and uh or
credit to all the hard work that you've
done thank you thank you
thank you Council McLaren Council Busby
is there anything else you'd like to add
uh I don't think so thank you thank you
so in that case
um I'd like to ask the corporate manager
governance
um and Civic office to conduct the
electronic vote but please note
um that we're moving the recommendations
with the amendment to I um
recommendation 3.3 are you happy about
that councilor Busby thank you
so I'd like to move to the electronics
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for cancers to cast their vote
thank you chair that voting is now
complete we have 15 votes four and one
abstention
thank you that vote is carried
so we'll now move on to item 15 in the
agenda
pay for BC 22 28.
joint local development scheme 2022-25
I would like to invite councilor arthi
to introduce paper 22 BC 2228 and to
move the recommendation in the report
councilor arthy
thank you chair
baber and mid suffolk's last joint local
development scheme or LDS was published
in July 2020.
in late 2020 both councils approved the
joint local plan pre-submission document
which was submitted to the then
Secretary of State for housing
communities and local government for
independent examination in early 2021.
as I'm sure you're you are aware a
significant amount of work has been
undertaken through the examination to
reach where we are today
following hearings held last year and
subsequent Communications with the
appointed planning inspectors The Joint
local plan the jlp is to be taken
forward in two parts
part one has been subject to discussion
at examination and is currently at the
modification stage prior to the next
consultation on modifications
work on part two has commenced
we need to formally review the LDS which
is the work program for update prior to
the part one modifications consultation
commencing
the LGs sets out the local planning
Authority's work program for the
preparation of development plan
documents over the period between 2022
and 2025.
we need to have an up-to-date LDS prior
to the consultation on modifications to
the part 1 jlp which is currently
anticipated to begin soon
there is also a legal requirement to
have an up-to-date LDS in place prior to
the adoption of the of a plan
the LDS formally introduces part one and
part two of jlp as agreed during the
examination that a meeting held with the
inspectors last year
the LDS also introduces a number of
supplementary planning documents or spds
to follow adoption of a part one joint
local plan and to provide more detail on
the implementation of planning policies
within that jlp
a revised timetable is also presented
for a review of the community
infrastructure Levy the seal charging
schedules
the LDS identifies that a part two joint
local plan will follow the part one
document and will contain an up-to-date
settlement hierarchy
a spatial distribution of any housing
allocations
a housing requirement figure for
neighborhood plan areas
individual site allocations
up-to-date settlement boundaries
reflecting commitments and site
allocations
open plan designations with a relevant
development management policy and
finally an up-to-date assessment
accommodation for the needs of gypsies
Travelers traveling show people and boat
dwellers
together with relevant development
management policies and if necessary
allocations to provide for the need
the indicative time scale outlines the
stages that are necessary for the
preparation of this development plan
document which will involve at least
three stages of public consultation
prior to the submission for examination
nine supplementary planning documents
are introduced with an initial focus on
affordable housing biodiversity and
trees well-being and health and
sustainable Construction
we need to bring this LDS into effect by
the 31st of October
to ensure that the progress being made
on the jlp can continue in accordance
with the current time timetable to
modifications consultation and
ultimately adoption next year
chair I'm proposing the recommendation
at 3.1
that the baber and mid-suffolk Joint
local development scheme
2022-2025 dated October 2022 at appendix
a is agreed to be brought into effect
from the 31st of October 2022.
thank you
thank you Council Arthur can I have a
second here please
councilor Busby
so we'll now move on to questions
counselors may ask as many questions
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question
any questions
counselor Busby
well I'll guess I'll ask the question
that everybody is likely to be asking
which is how on Earth can it take 10
years to produce a 25-year local plan
and
uh second question
how does this affect
planning decisions going forward what
what weight will this carry
planning process
councilor RC
right
um
I feel like I have I had to turn around
because there's nobody to look at over
there
as far as this document is concerned it
will carry no weight at all
but of course what it's doing is
timetabling the joint local plan work
and the supplementary planning documents
and they will carry weight they'll
continue to gather weight as they go
through the process
the other question I think you asked was
how come it's taken so long which is the
obvious question to ask
um
we started this process for the jlp in
2016.
so it's actually just over six years now
the planning inspectors teller inspector
tell us that the average time for the
preparation of a local plan is seven
years so we're going to be around about
the average
um
it was late 2020 as I said that we
introduced the submission document and
from the spring of last year we have
effectively been in the hands of the
planning inspector at the inspectors who
are examining our plan and so there's
very little that we can do from that
moment last year there's very little we
can do to actually accelerate the
process
thank you Council Busby
if I can come back on it um
well look I really
it's been a tiresome exercise I guess
and one Robert is probably going to be
glad to see the back of when we get to
2025 well those of us that might get to
2025.
um but there must be lessons that have
been learned on the way that
either we can tell the inspectors or
they can tell us about how to speed up
this process I mean it it is ridiculous
that it takes 10 years to produce a
25-year plan I know there's been a
hiccup in the middle but maybe we should
have anticipated that I don't know maybe
the inspector should get involved at a
much earlier stage I don't know whether
they can
but we must learn lessons from it we
can't get to 2025
and immediately have to start another
plan which will take another 10 years
sorry that was that a question how can
we avoid that
so I'll see
the answer to your question
um
it's always I mean I've been on the
council for a long time now and it's
always been the same with local plans
you have to start them at a point and
during the course of the preparation of
the plant lots of things change not
least of all
the guidance from the government
so as you know we've had the nppf and
its various changes come through during
the course of our plan
it is always the case I might bring Rob
in a minute but it is always the case
that you finish one plan and you're kind
of working on the next because it is a a
flow if you like I don't think Rob
ought to be glad to see the back of it
it's his job and he's very good at it
and I thank him for everything that he's
done and I'm sure he won't want his job
to come through an end when we finally
get part two
completed and adopted Rob I don't know
if you want so or even maybe Tom if you
want to say anything about that sort of
process in the plan
foreign
I think um I'd just like to point to two
things that happened during the
production of the plan one thing we had
the dedicated National play policy
framework was revised in 2018 and there
was also the introduction of standard
method so housing numbers which resulted
in uplift around 40 also we had a shift
to much more infrastructure-led approach
so we've spent a lot of time on the
infrastructure delivery plan making sure
that's comprehensive
um and we're always working in an
environment where policy changes so we
need to be alive to that but certainly
yeah we'll reflect on the past few years
and as we go ahead
Council Busby well I've actually thought
of an idea how to speed it up
wouldn't it be much quicker if every
village had a neighborhood plan
if every village had a label plan
wouldn't we just then staple them into a
binder and say there's our local plan
is that a rhetorical question
or wrong
well I'll stand up and talk just for a
minute or two because I can see that Tom
and Rob are having a chat about how to
answer a question like that
um my initial response is that
neighborhood plans deal with a a sort of
a a more
contained plan obviously because it's
for in the parish or they they can share
share parishes do two or three together
but it doesn't look at the overarching
needs of the district so when you come
on to things like the district housing
need the employment allocations I don't
think you would reply you could rely on
an individual Parish
to accommodate those sorts of needs I
think the answer to your question is no
you could not have a series of
neighborhood plans and staple them
together and call it a
plan
has that given you enough time to think
about if I can just add to that chair
s conservatively Rafi Riley points out
effectively plan a strategic policies as
well as local policies whereas neighbor
plans are our local policies of course
they're part of the development plan we
take account of them when we're
producing the local plan and we need to
work carefully when plans are being
produced in tandem but um you do have to
have the Strategic policies in
accordance with the Mbps
Council award
councilor Hinton
thank you Mr chairman let's be looking
at the LDS timetable for uh with all its
little colored boxes uh and I'm
I'm quite uh encouraged to see so many
of them actually coming to fruition
during the autumn
whenever that is
um because I think we're in Autumn now
aren't we in terms of meteorological
bits and pieces but for instance
biodiversity in trees will the US
a supplementary planning document on
biodiversity in trees do you have any
more protection to our trees than we
have at the moment where in our my
particular Ward it seems that developers
can chop down trees and enforcement
don't seem to do anything very much
about it
oh
Council Elsie
um
I suppose the short answer is yes
it will give more protection to trees
but um you've got to remember what it's
doing is it's increasing the importance
of trees and biodiversity in
developments so
it's it will be something that can be
used as a tool in the determination of
planning applications so the SPD will
hang off the policies in our new plan
part one so
I think what you're kind of asking is
will it help in terms of biodiversity
biodiversity net gain and wouldn't help
in terms of perhaps the overall tree
canopy cover for our district
um it won't have
an immediate big change it won't it
won't lead to anything happening
significantly
initially but it will control the way
that development happens usually the
policies in the plan so it will make a
difference will it mean that at least
Burger is all of a sudden surrounded by
Forest no
he wants to keep to keep dreaming okay
yes you can
I understand that these documents will
can't be applied retrospectively
but in theory our policies at the moment
mean that trees marked on plans that are
approved for development have to be
retained unless they're marked as being
scheduled for removal and yet in this
particular case in my in my ward three
300 year old oak trees have been removed
when they were supposed to be retained
now it takes 300 years to grow that to
grow those trees so it's not going to
influence the canopy very much
in the long term
immediately it's going to influence it
considerably because three trees have
suddenly vanished we were marked up as a
as a ward which was deficient if you
like entry canopy so we needed to plant
wall so yes we should be surrounding
have you got us questions please
what my my original question was will
this give any more protection because at
the moment in theory we've got
protection but this is not
it doesn't actually say that it's going
to give us a lot of protection because
it's a general canopy thing
right the councilor Hinton is talking
about a specific case yeah
um and I have been in communication with
him about it and it's being looked into
I don't really think we ought to go any
further into that specific case about
the loss of trees and weather we need to
take any action
publicly here today
I agree thank you councilor Gould
thank you chair and it leans nicely into
my question councilor Artie which is
will the LC Whip and these sustainable
travel
strategies feed into this tour or is
this not the place for them did I miss
it I didn't see Elsie whip
chilled I don't quite understand the
question I'm sorry
um the RC web will it feed into this
document at all the the information
that's on the LC with in terms of the
aspirational cycle and walking Pathways
that are there is is this an appropriate
place for that to feed into somehow or
not I mean the Arts might be not
um
I think there was some Talk of the the
LC work somehow
um connecting with the local development
plans
but um
I think we're
talking about the local development
scheme today which is the timetable for
what's going to happen I'm looking
hopefully towards Tom and Rob there I
think the question is more about will
the LC Wick be picked up in the jlp and
the supplementary supplement your
planning documents
I think is that the question yeah
yes yes
can we ask our officers to help here
please
yeah I
would give a our Rob is volunteering
thank you yeah the local cycling walking
infrastructure plan is very much
connected to the local plan in the
implementation of the transport policies
because it's a material consideration
plan decisions it's not a development
plan document or a submission plan
document than that right that's why it's
not negative okay
foreign
[Music]
and come this time next year there could
be 32 different councilors sitting here
so what are the risks that this could
drag on and on and on if those 32
councilors whether the same or different
have different opinions about The Joint
local player and the documents is there
a time is there a cut off tile you know
is there when it all we have to start
again
um yeah I'm gonna refer to Rob probably
in a minute but if you look at the
timetable I think it's fairly evident
from that that it's going to be too late
for part one
um if what you're saying is that we
could have a change of Council next year
and
um the new Council might say we want to
do it differently
um so part one I think will be done by
then if you look at the timetable for
part two that
is running over the election period next
May
so I mean I hope this is a a question
that will never need to be addressed but
I think the question is if we were to
have a change well we won't have a
change of Council next year would they
be able to
um
stop the progress of part two
chairman councilor Arthur's invitation
um it's
entirely normal for local plan progress
to straddle administrations as councilor
I think pointed to earlier it takes on
average seven years so that would almost
inevitably the development of a local
plan straddles administrations and
changes and elections and all those kind
of things
government through the department for
leveling up housing and communities have
indicated that all councils should have
an up-to-date plan in place by the end
of 2023 your part one
through the examination and then you
adopt that will achieve that for you
part two is within the gift of
counselors to determine how they wish to
take that forward following the election
next year
um I'm not really sure where else you
um
some councils find themselves in very
difficult positions because they get
down the towards the end of the line of
a local planning process and then choose
not to adopt uh
have taken a peer review a few weeks ago
where a council
considered doing that and we're
receiving a letter from dlac informing
them of the risks of doing that and that
they would find themselves in a position
of having to apply the presumption in
favor of sustainable development in
their planning decision taking because
because plan so right advice to
counselors would always be to get
yourselves an up-to-date plan as soon as
you can and when it's within your gift
and then commence work on a new one or
an amendment to one if you so choose to
can I also I mean I would be astonished
if there was a change in Council next
May is so significant that a majority of
those new councilors actually wanted to
abandon all of the work that we've done
all of the progress that we've made
um you know it has been six it will be
seven years by then I mean it would be a
an astonishingly
decision to make in my view so I
you've asked the question but I just
hope that the answer will
never be arrived at
councilor Huron
chairman thank you my comment is partly
statement possibly question
um in relation to um what councilor
Busby said earlier
I have read this and taken a great
interest in the joint local plan for the
last well it seems 20 years almost and I
can say this one is like no other our
last local plan wasn't great and that
was a rehash on the one before that I
think was written by the late Neil Greg
um this one seems to contain everything
down to the finest detail so I think
once you've got a local plan that's that
concise it shouldn't take too long to
update it and um and build on it and
hopefully it'll be a rolling process
that will be a lot quicker
and also I think the fact that so many
of our villagers have now done um
neighborhood plans it should help as
well
even if only for the education purposes
now every village tends to know what
it's about don't they and they're quite
well read and most of my Village have
got an expert who um has the information
at the fingers so um the next one in
update and should only take a couple of
years unless the government continue to
map with planning regulations in which
case we could all be in trouble but
um great plan great work um great hope
for the future thank you
councilor Horan we're veering into
debate here have you got a question at
the end of that
[Laughter]
chairman councilor Huron is absolutely
right it is the case that the amount of
work that's had to go into this I mean
it's a jlp so it's two councils so
there's obviously twice as much in terms
of in terms of
involved but yes it has been far more in
depth the amount of work that's been
involved has been that much greater I
think this is the third local plan that
I've been involved in since I was first
elected all those years ago and yes
you're absolutely right it
are very hopeful obviously we've we've
got part one with its modifications
coming soon
we're very hopeful that it will be the
best set of policies and the best
document that we've ever had for
controlling growth in the district for
Distributing growth in the district and
for determining planning applications
we seem to be more or less filthy or
answer
to be more or less into debate but does
anyone else have some further questions
before we move formally into debate
in that case shall we move into
debate here we seem to have almost
started it anyway but would anyone like
to cancel a ward thank you yeah thank
you madam chairman yeah I just wanted to
Muse a bit on the um uh the comments
that have been made about the amount of
time it's taking to do this
and I've I've spoken to council leaders
around the country and and uh there are
some Horror Story stories about the
length of time local plans are taking
and the delays that that occur during
the inspection process
uh close to home
I believe that tendering and Braintree
approved their local plans earlier this
year and it took each of them 17 years
to get to that stage
the dcn is constantly lobbying
government about this and and to be fair
the government themselves I think
understand that the current process is
not fit for purpose
um it's it's far too time consuming and
takes far too long
and I think that um they did the the
original leveling up and regeneration
bill
um was going to attempt to to improve
the process I think um and and make some
significant changes to the planning
system that was several secretaries have
seen the go and there's been very little
progress on that since earlier this year
but um I think the good news that
Michael Gove is now back in position
um I think uh bodes well for that and we
might see some further progress and we
might see hopefully a local plan making
process that um is is fit for purpose
going forward but at the moment we've
got to live with what we've got
foreign
else like to
join the debate
Council Arthur is there anything else
you'd like to add
I'd just like to thank John wardford
he's just said
um there has been comments about how
how the process has taken
um there was no bigger critic about the
length of time it was taken
um that than me back in 2018 and I think
it was for that reason that John asked
me to take the planning portfolio in
2019 and deliver a plan
and that's what I was very much hopeful
of doing
it
maybe
um fingers crossed that we will get part
one done and
um part two we'll have to wait for the
new Council but I have to say that I
especially in the early days when I was
trying to to get the submission document
to council
we tried incredibly hard Rob was put
under a lot of pressure
um
Tom and through Tom and help from Arthur
Giovanni are our chief executive as well
to get the resource that we needed to
get that complete and we as I said
earlier we got that to count seal by the
end of 2020 and the subsequent delays
have been frustrating but by agreeing
with the inspector's suggestions to
progress the plan in two parts we are at
least going to be able to get part one
hopefully beginning of next year um and
we are going to be well progressed with
part two hopefully for the following
year which is much much better than the
alternative of having to go back and
start someone will go halfway back
through the process and start again
Gathering new evidence and everything
and
um
having part one and then hopefully
having part two is as I said in arts to
councilor Jameson's question is
infinitely better than aborting the
mission after
one
and to restart to try and do something
with part two so I've I've been well
aware of the delays I've been well aware
of the promise that I made to John and
to council back in 2019 and I think I
can say that I've partially succeeded
but unfortunately
we have had a delay since submission
thank you for the explanation and
summary councilor arthi
um so now I think we'll move on to the
vote
um I will ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you thank you
chair that vote is now showing in blue
for councilors to cast their vote
councilor Creswell oh it's just gone
through
um chair that is 16 votes for
thank you that is carried
we'll now move on to item 16.
paper BC 22 29 decisions taken by the
chief executive under delegated powers
in accordance with part two of The
Constitution I would like to invite the
chief executive to introduce this report
which is for ratification by Council
thank you chairman as councilors will
recall we weren't able to appoint a
monitoring officer at the last full
council meeting earlier this month but
as I indicated to you at that time we
would be doing so and I would use my
Powers outside of the meeting in order
to appoint a monitoring officer if I
needed to do so I have done that
um that report is in front of you though
and my request this evening is that you
ratify the decision that I made to
appoint FD who uh the chairman
introduced at the beginning the meeting
as our formal monitoring officer so I'll
need to move in a second thank you Jim
thank you Council award thank you
councilor Davis seconding
the recommendation is that Council
ratifies the decision taken under
delegated powers by the chief executive
unless members have any questions and
tend to put this straight to the vote
so thank you I will now ask the
corporate manager Governors and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for members to cross their vote
chair that is 16 votes for that is
unanimous
well that's fortunate
thank you
so we'll now move on to item 17. sort of
sorry so that is carried
um so we'll now move on to item BC 2230
the draft timetable of committee
meetings 2023-24
I'd like to invite councilor Ward to
introduce paper BC 2230 and to move the
recommendations in the report Council
award
thank you madam chairman well it's quite
simple and straightforward this is the
timetable for committee meetings for the
next Municipal year 2023 to 2024.
um the the dates have been drawn up in
consultation with SLT and the committee
chairs uh it's not really a lot to say
about it
um I don't think we and many of us have
got any
um questions over the dates after all
quite a lot of us might not be here
after May 23 so it won't really matter
well yes
um so yes I'd just like to propose the
recommendations in paragraph two of the
report that um we accept the timetable
thank you Council Ward so unless anyone
has any questions oh sorry yes I need a
second uh
Council McLaren
so unless anyone has any questions I
intend to put this straight to the vote
this is with oh we have a question yes
councilor Hamilton
thank you very much
just just a quick one I'll just spotted
looking at it there's a planning
committee for baber organized for the
day before the elections
um can you email in that query please
against the fourth of May
so I'm being told that that can be
answered now I'm chair regulatory
committees can still continue through
the moratorium period so um hence we
will be continuing with planning and
Licensing if needed
thank you so any further queries can be
emailed to Jan following the meeting
okay so
um thank you I'll now ask the corporate
manager Governors and Civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that is in progress for
you to cast your votes
chair that is 16 votes for again
unanimous thank you so that's carried
item 18
BC 2231 recommendations from the
Independent remuneration panel I would
like to invite the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to introduce
this report
thank you chair this report presents to
council the findings of a review of the
cancer scheme of allowances by the
independent remuneration panel who are
unfortunately not able to be with us
tonight
under the local Authority's members
allowances England regulations 2003 the
regulations the council is required to
establish and maintain an independent
remuneration panel to make
recommendations to council about the
allowances to be paid to members
it is important that the council
appoints an independent remuneration
panel and pays due regard to the views
of the panel before any decisions are
made in respect and changes to the
scheme of allowances for members
as part of the review a questionnaire
was issued to all councilors to support
and inform the review responses will
received from 39 of the 66 current
councilors that's a 59 response the
information attained was helpful in
forming the irp's deliberations the IRP
interviewed eight current councilors
using a structured questioning process
within focus groups across both
authorities an opportunity was also
given for individual counselors to be
interviewed if they wished or to submit
comments to the panel
as part of the review the IRP also
examined the current scheme for both
authorities and highlighted differences
made and made comparative reviews from
other similar authorities
they also examined the report from the
previous review and took into account
the councilor role descriptions and
their terms of reference
the panel also met with the chief
executive the irp's report and their
findings are detailed in the appendix a
of the papers
it should be noted that the review had
taken place before the full extent of
the cost of the living crisis was known
and as the previous scheme was backdated
to 2017 to accommodate the changes in
the governance Arrangements that took
place at that time the indexing for the
current screen has stopped in 2021 as
the legislation only allows for the
um a scheme to be indexed for four years
therefore there will be no uplift to the
councilor announce scheme in this year
cancers will need to take those factors
into account when considering the report
before them finally I would like to
thank the IRP panel for their
comprehensive review of the scheme thank
you chair
thank you
because this report is from the
Independent remuneration panel and not
table by a counselor I intend to move
the recommendations in the report and
ask for a seconder please
could I have a second counselor John
Osborne thank you
councilor Ward I believe you wish to
table an amendment
thank you madam chairman yes I I do
um and as you'll all know following the
independent remuneration panels report a
cross-party working group of the two
councils will set up to review the
panel's recommendations as a result of
this some changes were deemed to be
necessary and these can be found in
appendix F of the report
I would just like to summarize these
with the reasoning behind them
the working group thought that the
public service discount of 40
recommended by the panel was too high
based on the responses received from
members we have reduced this to 35
this has been applied to the basic
allowance and is propagated to the other
allowances through the stated
multipliers
the working group also wanted to ensure
that the annual uplift for the current
year is included in line with local
government pay Awards and so a six
percent increase equivalent to the
current officer inflation increase for
2022-23 has been included in the basic
allowance
there was quite a bit of discussion
about the recommendation concerning the
number of special responsibility
allowances and that an individual
counselor could play
the working group thought that the
Restriction to just one was not
practical given the number of councilors
we now have and also it didn't reflect
the increased workloads of the councilor
with more than one responsibility has
it therefore decided to revise this to
no more than two sras
and finally the working group wanted to
ensure that the revised allowance scheme
should only come into Force for the new
Council and so the effective date has
been put back to 8th of May 2023.
so I'd therefore like to propose the
amended recommendations detailed in
appendix F I would ask for a second to
please
can I just say
yes just a couple of brief words
endorse this the recommendation because
it also makes it very clear
the original proposals talked about
political group leaders
of
well you find the right page again I've
lost it now
Group Leaders with more than five
members and grouped Leaders with less
than five members which left five
members in limbo whereas this one
addresses it because it does say
political group leaders of five or more
members and political group leaders of
less and five members so that clarifies
that issue there
thank you councilor Hinton so we'll now
move on to questions on the amendment or
was there something you should say
councilor award well I just want to
mentioned whether you would accept the
amendment as it sounds
up to the amendment
yes so we can do that
um do I need to start a secondary you
just need to ask councilor Osborne if
she's happy oh cancer Osborne are you
happy
I just have clarification on what the
amendment is again please before I put
my
Council Ward the amendment and the
details in appendix f
which the Council of working group put
together based on on its liberations
right okay so are there any questions on
the amendment please
councilor Aussie I'm just
justification really
um and that is the
the three it doesn't apply to us
that is correct with the revision of the
implementation day to eight of May that
would be correct
correct
so once the we're going to vote on it
now and then we can debate this debate
it once it's become a substantive motion
thank you
so if if no one has any objections well
we'll we'll now vote on the amendment
that you've heard from councilor Ward
and then if that is passed that will
become the substantive motion and then
we can have questions and debate on that
okay so we will now move to the vote
voting on the amendment
um
I'd like to ask the corporate manager of
governance and Civic office to conduct
of the electronic vote on the amendment
chair that is 16 votes for the amendment
thank you so that has now been carried
so that now becomes a substantive motion
and so now we can move to questions
debate on the amendment and that is now
the substantive motion so would anyone
like to open with the question
if there are no questions we'll move to
debate
councilor Davis
thank you yes um
no it's
an integration panel I understand that
and I'm even more concerned at this time
with the cost of living crisis there's
so many other people struggling to get
pay Rises
however that said
um heartened that the panel has looked
at this and linked it with officers pay
for example which is a good for me a
good comparison because it says we're
not being paid excessively over the top
and I say we actually it may not be us
as you know because it won't come into
effect until the new Administration
comes in so again I think that's a
positive point in terms of the public
understanding that we're not giving
ourselves a pay rise we're given the
administration next time around an
increase and I think it's also worth
pointing out because it can be difficult
for sometimes for the public people
watching this to understand
why we need to increase the payments
that even albeit gradually I voted
against it four years ago five years ago
but this year I will be voting for it
because I think it's important that new
councilors they see what the is so when
they're coming into it when they stand
for election they can see the money that
the allowances they get it won't make
them rich but the whole point of being a
council I believe is to represent
the residents not yachty not you
particularly individual views but your
residents and that's the main reason why
I think people should go into local
Authority especially at District Council
level and above
thank you thank you councilor Davis
any other comments councilor Busby
yeah well I I mean I agree with Derek um
except
uh
we're cheap
if this was in if we were doing this job
in a in a private sector we'd be getting
10 times what we're being paid here this
is just an allowance it's almost pocket
money it seems like
and really it might become a point where
we have to start thinking of it as a
salary to encourage people to come in I
mean at the moment it's easier to get a
new prime minister than it is to get
people to stand as a counselor
only just
um so I mean I don't have any problem
with the increase we're not
tying our
um allowances into the salaries
off it's just the rate of increase
so anybody thinks that we're going to
get paid the same kind of rate as our
wonderful staff that is a mistake but I
haven't got a problem with
you know having this paper I think they
work very hard for it
thank you councilor Busby
would anyone else conser RC
yeah I was going to say something about
the timing
um because I can remember several
occasions in the past when we've had to
do a similar exercise and the timing is
never right
I think this time round the timing is
ideal because we are not doing anything
that will affect our remuneration in the
past there have been suggestions that
things could be backdated to the time
when the last review Provisions ran out
or something
um but what we're doing here is that
we're setting the scene for the
councilors that will be elected next
year and I think it's essential that
they should know what the remuneration
for what they're going to be doing is
um I think the other important things in
there are that we've got provision for
Child Care Independence allowance which
I think is really important and that we
will also be formulating a policy on
Parental leave and I think it's
important that councilors know that
we're doing that so that when they
consider standing for election next may
they know exactly what they're going to
be able to to provide for so I'm fully
supportive of
I was fully supportive of the original
proposal and I'm fully supportive of
John Ward's Amendment as well
thank you councilor arthi would anyone
else like to comment
thank you well if no one else um would
like to join the debate we'll now move
on to the electronic vote
thank you and I'll ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic vote on the
oh on the amendment
thank you chair that is detailed um as
appendix F of the report and showing in
blue for cancers to cast their vote
foreign
thank you chair that is 15 votes for and
one abstention
so that's carried
item 20
counselor appointments
are there any changes to placings
no
so now we'll move on to motions on
notice
please note that the motion from
councilor Lindsay that was due to come
back to this council is with legal
officers to sign off and therefore we'll
be coming forward to the next meeting
so that's the end of this evening's
meeting please note the date of the next
meeting is Tuesday 22nd November 2022 at
5 30. thank you very much all of you
that have attended this evening it's
been very good to see those of you that
are here